[Music]
so Avengers infinity war has been out
for over a week now and it's pretty
obvious that it's an amazing movie and
not to mention it is just destroying all
sorts of box office records and if
you've seen the movie
you're probably wondering just like
everybody else what exactly is going to
happen in Avengers 4 if you haven't seen
Avengers infinity war yet this is
probably a little bit of a redundant
video and I'm sorry but of course this
will have spoilers in it so obviously
none of us are 100% sure of what
Avengers 4 is going to be about but we
obviously know that in Avengers 4
they're going to have to figure out a
way to try and attempt to undo what
happened in Avengers infinity war not
much has been said about what's going to
happen in Avengers 4 but in a recent
interview Sebastian Stan may have given
us some clues of what will happen in
Avengers 4 before we dive into it don't
forget about our speaker giveaway to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel subscribe to the stupendous
waves channel leave a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero the giveaway will end and the
winner will be announced on may 30th so
during a recent interview with Sebastian
stander in the Q&A session a fan asked
him about him taking over as Captain
America if Steve Rogers dies in Avengers
4 most of you know that Chris Evans did
not renew his contract to play Captain
America after Avengers 4 so most of us
believe that that if he dies is more of
a when he does an Sebastian Stan's
answer to the question pushes me more to
believe that Captain America will in
fact die in Avengers 4 he starts off his
answer by saying I mean look you know it
would have to be a very different you
know quote Captain America it just
wouldn't be the same he then goes on to
talk about the emotional turmoil and the
guilt that Bucky faces in the comics
because Captain America is dead but it's
his concluding remarks that lead me to
believe that in Avengers 4 Captain
America will die he says so if they ever
were to explore that it would be a very
different definitely way darker take on
the situation you know for those of you
who aren't familiar with the comics
Bucky becomes Captain America post-civil
war after
Captain America is dead but he then
learns that Steve Rogers made Tony Stark
promise him two things one to rescue
Barnes from his descent into violence
and insanity and two to pass the Captain
America identity to a successor Tony
Stark decides that the best way to honor
both of those promises is to make Bucky
the new Captain America so it seems to
make sense that Captain America will die
in Avengers four and that Bucky will
become the new Captain America
especially because Chris Evans didn't
renew his contract and Sebastian Stan
signed on for nine movies now I know
what you must be thinking
Oh mr. Wonder Captain America is live
and Bucky's dead after infinity war I
know so this is obviously me assuming
that in Avengers four they will somehow
bring everyone who died back to life and
that brings me into my theory on how
Captain America could die sonne Avengers
infinity war we found out that in order
to obtain the soul stone you must
sacrifice the life of someone you love
in order to obtain it many people
believe that Tony Stark is going to be
the one that obtains the soul stone so
if Tony is the one that's going to
obtain the soul stone then he has to
sacrifice someone that he loves to get
it so who does he love we know that he
loves pepper but he's not gonna
sacrifice pepper and she might not even
be alive we don't know if she survived
after the universe getting wiped out he
could possibly love Peter Parker after
all he was sort of a father figure to
him but he is currently not alive thanks
to Thanos they may have had their
differences but he certainly does love
Steve Rogers the knowing good ol captain
he would gladly and probably insist that
Tony sacrifice him for the greater good
this is just one of literally thousands
of ways that they could potentially kill
off Captain America and have good old
Bucky come in and take the mantle and in
the comics Bucky feels an extreme amount
of guilt for a Captain America dying and
this would line up in the MCU if in
order to bring him back
Captain America had to die again this is
just a personal theory and there could
be thousands of ways that they could
kill Captain America or they could even
have him stay alive and retire somehow
either way I do think that Bucky will
take on the role of Captain America then
again he could just remain the white
wolf although it does seem like it's
pointing more towards him becoming
in America what do you all think you
think Captain America is gonna say
goodbye and Avengers floor or do you
think he's gonna survive and retire
somehow and either way do you think that
Bucky will become Captain America let me
know what you think in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video give
it a like and don't forget to subscribe
to my channel to join the wolf gang and
be entered in our giveaway to win a full
speaker system thank you so much for
watching
woof woof